[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who's
dying to find out if he's immortal or
not
in this video we're breaking down
episode six of invincible
the entry is packed with tons of
callbacks to the comics as well as some
big deviations that never happen in the
source material
there's also a huge thing being teased
through the immortal
and it could hint to nolan's secret
coming out soon we're going to be
breaking it all down but this is a
spoiler warning for the show and
parts of the comic up until this point
if you enjoy the video then please drop
a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for videos
like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now that's getting too invincible
okay so up top i want to add in some
easter eggs that we missed last time
firstly is one of the coolest callbacks
i've ever seen
and in the show we watches mark attends
reginald veljohnson high school
now the actor reginald val johnson plays
principal winslow
and why this is crazy is because he also
played carl winslow in family matters
to make things even weirder principal
winslow in the comics looked exactly
like how he does in the show
and in the show he looks like reginald
val johnson
making for one mind-blowing easter egg
in episode 1 we were also introduced to
martian man
and saw him with a young girl at one
point omniman of course killed the
superhero
and it doesn't look like things have
gotten better for said girl because
last week you could catch her in the
homeless shelter
yay what an uplifting storyline now at
the end of episode 3
in the supermax prison we could also
catch duplicates brother
multiple but whether he's gonna be in
the show more we'll just have to wait
and see
now episode 6 primarily centers around
mad scientist die sinclair
in the comics he first showed up in
issue 20 which just so happened to
follow on
immediately after the titan crime boss
won this happens
way later than a lot of stuff in the
series such as the first chapter in the
omni man arc
showing that they are reordering a lot
of things the episode is very much a
compression of sinclair's entire rock
and in the comics when he first showed
up we discovered he'd been reanimating
the dead in order to make them killer
robots known as rihanna men
the end of issue 22 was when he decided
to start using live test subjects
and he was absent for over a year in the
comics not returning until issue 36
37 was where the arc culminated but they
kind of pushed everything together from
these issues into one big story
the arc about first creating the rihanna
men from corpses is just tinted at
and instead we jump immediately into the
a kidnapping live test subjects from
upstate university this was the one that
mark was actually attending in the
comics when d.a started his criminal
activities
but for the show he's still in high
school elsewhere
mark monster girl and black samson are
rushed into er
after they were brutally beaten by
battle beasts last week
the doctors are almost killed when
trying to operate on her and i feel this
is somewhat a call back to spider-man 2
namely the doctor octopus seen in the
hospital
robot is the only one who can operate on
her and we learn that he has studied her
physiology
in issue 15 of the comics the character
actually took a skin sample from her
which does explain this moment none of
these operations scenes were present in
the source material
and in fact it was bulletproof that was
almost killed by battlebeast
to add more mark's recovery is far
greater
and whereas in the original work he just
ended up with some cuts and plasters
here he's out for six days now
personally i love this extra character
development
and helps to show how much of a bad
father that nolan is
after seeing that he was present when
the fight was going on we know that he
has a much darker side to him
and all of the characters around him are
becoming victim to it
from here we see the continuation of
cecil's suspicions
and he keeps up the lie that damian dark
blood is the one suspected of killing
the guardians
as we know nolan placed their blood in
his office in order to frame him
and while cecil and co study mark's
blood in order to find a weakness for
the veltromites
they have to pretend that omniman is in
the clear however the conversation that
cecil and nolan have
is very much laced with the subtext that
the former is asking the latter exactly
why he did it
nolan gives the answer that he's a demon
which is why and though this isn't to be
taken literally
omniman of course has a devilish side to
him
and this confirms mephisto sorry wrong
show
and the two also discuss velcro and how
on the planet
teenagers listen to their parents this
showcases that their civilization has a
lot of order to it
and though i can't talk about the big
things without spoiling too much
let's just say voltromites are very
encouraged to join the world betterment
committee when they come of age
this makes them believe that beltrum is
supreme and they go planet to planet
instilling their ways throughout the
galaxy this very much juxtaposes mark's
attitude
and nolan clearly hates that his son
disobeyed him and thus he's willing to
see him suffer because of it
potentially this shows that he wants
mark on his side
and he's allowed him to see that if he
doesn't listen to him bad things will
happen
mark pretends he's been hit by a car and
after making things right with amber we
jump to him and his best friend william
throughout the entry we see william and
rick develop their relationship
and later learn that the latter has been
kidnapped by sinclair
rick and william actually end up dating
in the comics so i appreciate that
there's some lip service paid to them
dating throughout
cut to mark's room and we can see him
packing and also catch on the wall the
saiyan stock poster which resembles
doctor strange
now i forgot to mention last time that
this is actually playing on science dog
a character that somewhat shows up in
issue 25 of the comics
they've changed him up quite a lot for
this making him magic
instead of the way that he was
originally adam eve arrives and she
states she's realized that the cape [ __ ]
isn't the best way to save people and
that she can make an actual difference
helping them on a human level in the
comics the character actually went to
africa
mainly to find solitude whereas here
they've changed it up quite a lot
though she builds an african-looking
tree house she still remains in what
looks like america and helps at home
rather than abroad in issue 22 she flew
into an african village and changed the
landscape into luscious greenland
but here she stops a forest fire
rockslide and creates crops for some
farmers
either way it adds a lot to the
character in my opinion and showcases
that you can be a hero in ways other
than just fighting bad guys
in issue 20 of the comics a similar
conversation happened where eve talked
about how everyone underestimated her
and it's ice that they do sort of echo
it here she is a character that can
control reality
but she's been reduced to simply
fighting bank robbers and aliens
because of the role that she's found
herself in it adds way more to her and
we get the idea that she's
actually in it for the right reasons
whereas most of the other teen team
were after the glory we see an
interaction that she has with her father
who says he wants nothing more than for
her to have a normal life
but she disobeys him and continues to
help people out
this idea of standing against one's
parents is very much something that i
think is foreshadowing the ark that mark
will go on
and i believe that he will wrestle with
siding with his father or against him as
we go further into the season
as soon as mark leaves we see debbie
drop the facade and nolan realizes that
something is up which is when he checks
his costume
i kind of have a bit of a problem with
this storyline as i don't know why
omniman would have hid the costume here
when the guy is able to travel to the
sun in a second and there's so many
other places on the planet he could have
put it to not arouse suspicion
either way speaking of aroused william
gets that when he checks out rick's butt
and we also see a tour of the campus
it's alerted with missing posters
namely one for doug chesterton who was
of course kidnapped at the start of the
episode
there's also a house party one which
becomes a big plot motif later on
the group go to a lecture which is
interrupted by d.a sinclair
which is pretty much ripped directly out
of the comics namely issue
20 once more however they add more to it
as this is where sinclair meets rick and
he realizes that he's an alpha male
later on he spies on him and this
plotline didn't appear until two issues
later
when he just simply smacked him on the
head as he was going to his room
ambra mark spends some uninterrupted
time together and they decide to both
attend the university
however the piece is disturbed by the
arrival of one of the rihanna men
and it lets us know that no matter how
much mark tries to have a normal life
things like this will always disrupt it
whereas nolan was happy to sit around
and have dinner with his wife
mark's duty and responsibility simply
won't allow him to
and he sacrifices his image to amber in
order to be a savior
the action scene is ripped straight out
of issue 20 once more
and these robocop inspired enemies are
some of the most memorable foes that
mark encounters
due to this fight william two discovers
that mark is invincible
which alters things slightly from the
source material as he figured it out by
just
kind of putting everything together it
was it was pretty obvious let's be
honest
now the rihanna man goes mad upon seeing
his reflection
and he impales himself in order to end
the living hell that he's trapped in
elsewhere robot visits monster girl in
the hospital
and he carries with him a rare blue
flower that's come from the arctic
might be reaching here but i think that
this is a reference to batman begins
in which bruce had to retrieve one in
order to continue his journey
a robot somewhat gives the game away a
bit here as he shows he has
drones and several bodies samson also
realizes that he has an attachment to
monster girl
hinting to him being more than just an
android we later see him with the
maulers
and they are halfway through the cloning
process having already duplicated most
of rexplo's internal organs
after realizing that robot will likely
double-cross them
they go and dig up the immortal in order
to have some insurance
this is actually how the episode ends
and it's a big deviation from the source
material
in that they actually brought him back
to life before any of the cloning plot
and this was requested by robot after
the ending of episode 3 i
did think that this would be the
direction that they would be heading but
it's nice that they've switched things
up
and it does allow for things to
differentiate from the comics
at arts debbie and he discovered that
nolan was the one who killed the
guardians
due to the marks in his outfit having
the signatures of their weapons and
abilities
this is a big change up from the comics
as neither discovered this on their own
and i actually think that because of
this nolan will kill out
this isn't something that happened in
the source material at all but obviously
he doesn't want this getting out
and the less people that know the better
i think that after this
nolan will struggle with whether to kill
his wife or not and it might be
something that he has to make a tough
decision over
say he did kill her or even harmed her
then this is something that his
relationship with mark would simply
never recover from
to make matters worse mark looks like a
lot of the relationships he has with
people close to him are going to be
destroyed
when amber meets kyle now though this is
a brand new character
i think it might be based on gary from
the comics who predominantly appears in
issue 14 41
he creates somewhat of a love square
between amber mark and eve
and very much adds another dynamic at
one point amber and gary hang out and he
gets called by his boss who wants him to
go into work
he says no because he wants to spend
time with amber and this very much
juxtaposes how mark constantly rushes
off it makes her question her feelings
for him
and though we don't know how the
relationship is going to develop it does
seem like it might be following a
similar sort of route
mark attends the party but has to bail
out before he can repair the damage
because william has decided to go into
the sewers like
issue 36 and 37 will is strapped down to
the operating table
and we discover that rick has been made
into a monster his helmet is removed
and at this point he looks extremely
similar to peter weller in robocop
he's under a trance but when when
william gets uh
personal he records his life and frees
himself
william goes wild on d.a and invincible
breaks his jaw for his crimes against
humanity
he does survive though and in the comics
we discover that cecil has
basically taken him into his employ mark
returns disheveled
and amboli's awake feeling down about
him however he returns to her bed
feeling happy for once and we watch as
nolan then returns home
whenever you walk in late at night and
find your wife in the dark drinking wine
you know it's gonna kick off and kick
off it does
debbie comes straight out with it and
says she knows he killed the guardians
but he denies the allegations and then
starts to gaslight her
nolan puts a hole in the wall and we
close out on him with his holes
surrounding him
metaphorically symbolizing the one that
he stuck himself into
this whole digging symbolism is carried
across to the credits scene
which is set in a graveyard and it
involves matt who you may remember from
the start of episode 2.
his stepfather opened episode 1 and the
pair traveled to london for the
follow-up entry
he and his friend believe that if they
dig the immortal up and drink from his
skull
that they'll get his powers because one
of them read it on reddit however
they're stopped by the maulers
and full full full spoilers ahead from
this point onwards
in regards to the immortal and robot now
in the comics as mentioned
the mullers brought the immortal back
upon waking he of course remembered that
omniman had murdered him
and he went after him which put a time
limit on nolan's actions
with us having just two episodes left i
can see that being the case
and thus he will be pushed to move
forward with the big reveal
as for robot in the comics when the
maulers moved his mind into the rex
clone
he betrayed them and said he was sending
them back to jail
the character used a drone to do this
but if they now have the immortal on
their side
then it might turn the tide in stopping
this from happening either way it's
going to be interesting to see what goes
down
and i have to say this was another great
episode in the comics the culmination of
the mars arc happened immediately after
the rihannamen one
so hopefully fingers crossed we'll be
getting that next week
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zach science justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the last episode
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul let's
see you next time
take care peace